it depends the way we are we are to fix
the greatest problem because otherwise
it could be a disaster despite the fact
that we are not the members of the
European Union but it severely affected
even Ukraine because look Greece
definitely needs austerity and Ukrainian
people already suffered too much and my
government passes three austerity
packages the same your government did
few years ago so we can actually share
an experience with our Greek France how
to pass reforms and how to make your
economy more vibrant and more robust so
the battery problem will be fixed the
quick of this problem will be fixed the
better for the world I mean you wouldn't
agree that more austerity will simply
shrink the Greek economy worse and in
the long run worse than that situation
of there is no just another option this
is the only option to pass painful tough
but necessary reforms in order to make
Greece strong economically and in order
to make European Union a viable project
but there has at some point gotta be
some debt relief as well as long well
the same goes in Ukraine we started debt
restructuring operation and we believe
that Ukrainian private creditors will be
collaborative and cooperative in
supporting Ukraine well it depends on
the talks between the EU in Greece we've
seen Prime Minister tsipras go to meet
President Putin a number of times or do
you believe is going on there I believe
this is not the right destination to go
to do you think President Putin does see
an opportunity to find a [ __ ] if you
like in the Western arm what Putin wants
Putin wants to have the daylight between
for example Greece and another EU member
states so he wants to split the unity in
the European Union he wants to split the
unity between the US and EU so he wants
actually to escalate the situation in to
trigger tensions inside the EU so this
is the aim of Russia to create a hot
spots in the entire world the same style
Soviets did 20 or 30 years ago when they
got troubles inside the Soviet Union
they usually redirected attention from
domestic staff to the outside one there
are those you say that what this is
really about
is her pride in Russia wanting to
reestablish its own as inference
certainly in ukraine russia wants to
disturb late the situation and you know
that we have this notorious means deal
mm-hmm which is actually a road map how
to de-escalate the situation and how to
get rid of Russian forces and Ukraine on
each side did everything to be whiter
than white in implementing the means
deal but Russia is not doing anything on
their side now cease fire now Russian
forces pull back so still we believe
that more than 40,000 troops 10 of which
belong definitely to Russian regular
military forces are stationed in Ukraine
Russia is to realize that these world is
another then President Putin things
about so they have to behave like a
responsible p five-member they are not
allowed to violate international law and
they are to pay the price for illegal
annexation of Crimea and for the
invasion of Donetsk and Lugansk because
Russia is still denying that it has
troops in Ukraine even although one of
our reporters Katie salad went to Russia
found the graves the soldiers have been
killed in Ukraine and yet the
international community has kind of
shied away from making an issue about
this do you think that's the right
approach the only country who denies the
presence of Russian soldiers in Ukraine
is Russia and the only person who says
no it's not we it's President Putin but
I can strongly recommend to Russian
regime just to switch on internet and to
get the footage in YouTube of their
troops their tanks and their artillery
oh the world has a number of issues on
the table and we do understand this Iran
I seal Ukraine grace Greece but this is
on the same line on the same level and
we are to act in concert and we are to
stay united to find an appropriate and
strong response to Russian light
aggression this is in the interest of
the entire free world as
shop or dez de thread pulls the threat
not only to Ukraine so what more would
you like countries like Britain and
Canada and the United States and France
where you've been visiting on this trip
what what what more would you like them
to do I just met President Obama Vice
President Biden Prime Minister Harper
and Prime Minister David Cameron and I
want to be very clear and open the
Western world is doing everything to
support Ukraine well it's normal when we
want to get more but we already got
financial support economic support
political support and even some kind of
military support we always ask for the
defensive weapon and we strongly believe
that the Western powers will consider
this idea strongly so once again we
protect not only Ukrainian borders we
are defending to you but I have said for
example that are not going to supply you
with lethal weapons and it's very
apparent that the deployment of military
force in support of Ukraine is not on
the agenda well we do understand that
there is no chance to reclaim the east
of Ukraine with the military forces but
the thing is that we ask for the
defensive weapon but not just for
offensive on the defensive weapon to
deter Russian led troops we are the only
country who is fighting against the
Russian army so help us so what would
you characterize as a defensive weapon
well defensive weapon anti-tank
electronic warfare and navigation system
everything that makes Ukrainian military
more durable and strong to continue to
deter Russian lead army isn't the truth
though tragic though it is for your
country that the West has decided that
Ukraine if you like is no man's land
there was a decision by NATO in 2008 to
only go for Associate status similarly
with the European Union we have to draw
the lessons from the past you know when
Ukraine and Georgia asked for membership
action plan in 2008 were referring it
and we are refused what happened next
Russia invaded Georgia and then Russia
illegally annexed Crimea
and then Russia invaded the east of
Ukraine and then Russia sandbar jets to
your borders and started to intimidate
Alliance NATO member states so let's
just realize that we have to change the
policy towards Russia do you think it
would be reversible in Russia after
President Putin is it about a man and
the style of leadership or is it
actually about in your view the stance
of a nation I wish better future to the
Russian people things will change the
well has changed already what about the
situation in the end of part of Ukraine
that you do control you've had a
standoff over this weekend with the
far-right party and roadblocks put up
and access to government troops not
given there so it's by no means table
outside of eastern Ukraine see well we
lost twenty percent of Ukrainian economy
and we'll also in percent of Ukrainian
territory but we are still in control of
ninety-three percent so we are
confronting a number of challenges both
military economic financial we will come
through this we already survived in the
last 17 months we have very strong
nation in strong country and the
democratic legitimacy of your own
government I mean you are in support has
been gained down quite dramatically well
that's normal because my government
started to very painful in top reforms
passing three austerity package and
having high approval rating this can't
match but I do understand that the
government is to bear the brunt for
these painful reforms we are working for
the future and finally optimistic
sidorio what would you like to happen
over the next 12 months realistically
regarding Ukraine and standoff in
eastern Ukraine as well after the
revolution we have not just the
territory we got the country and not
just the people but the really strong
nation we will make a success case story
but we need the support Ukrainian people
have sacrificed too much this is a this
is to be our joint quest the quest of
the free world to support Ukraine and
to win to win this battle yes yes thank
you very much indeed